Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I know I have the body of a weak and feeble woman, but I have the heart and stomach of a king, and of a king of England too. So spoke Elizabeth I as she reviewed her troops at Tilbury on the 18th of August 1588, the summer of the Spanish Armada. That she was by the standards of the age an old woman with black teeth and a red wig did not prevent her words from serving as one of the Spanish Armada. That she was by the standards of the age, an old woman with black teeth and a red wig did not prevent her words from serving as one of the great rallying cries in English history.
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的加更节目、享受无广告体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我知道我拥有一个柔弱女子的躯体，但我拥有国王的心和胆量，而且是英格兰国王的。1588年8月18日，在西班牙无敌舰队来袭的那个夏天，伊丽莎白一世在提尔伯里检阅军队时如是说。尽管以当时的眼光来看，她已是一位牙齿发黑、戴着红假发的年迈妇人，但这丝毫不影响她的这番话成为英格兰历史上最伟大的战斗檄文之一。
And Elizabeth herself from serving in the imaginings of her contemporaries as the very model of a great ruler, Gloriana, the Virgin Queen. And that's a role that basically she continues to serve to the present day. Dominic sandbrook with me as ever um i realized that this is actually the first time we've done a podcast
而伊丽莎白本人，在同时代人的想象中，也成为了伟大统治者的典范——“光荣女王”（Gloriana），童贞女王。这个角色她基本上一直扮演到了今天。多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）一如既往地与我在一起。嗯，我意识到这实际上是我们第一次做一期专门针对某一个人的播客。
devoted to one person yes uh and i do you think that she merits this accolade i hope you do well i obviously i obviously was holding out for a podcast on the life of James Callaghan. But weirdly, there doesn't seem as much demand among the listeners as I had thought. So I think Elizabeth I is a good second best. Of course, she is a colossal figure in the kind of iconography of England. And I think actually weirdly post-Brexit, you know, this woman defying, you know, the European invader. I mean, she's sort of enshrined in our collective imagination. Think of all the films and stuff. So actually, I think she's a great subject.
是的，而且你认为她值得这个赞誉吗？我希望你觉得值得。好吧，我显然一直在期待一期关于詹姆斯·卡拉汉（James Callaghan）生平的播客。但奇怪的是，听众对此似乎并没有我想象中那么大的需求。所以我认为伊丽莎白一世是第二好的选择。当然，她在英格兰的偶像体系中是一个极其宏大的人物。而且我认为，奇怪的是，在后脱欧时代，你知道，这位女性反抗了欧洲入侵者。我的意思是，她某种程度上被铭刻在我们的集体想象中。想想所有的电影之类的。所以实际上，我认为她是一个很棒的主题。
I mean, not least because of stuff that people project onto her. And maybe our guest today can help us, you know, strip away some of the myths and get to the real story. Yes, because a great subject needs a great guest. And our guest is certainly that. It's the historian Tracey Borman, author of a range of highly acclaimed books on Tudor England. And among those, germainly for our purposes, is Elizabeth's Women, the hidden story of the Virgin Queen. Tracey, thank you so much for joining us. It's my great pleasure. Although
我的意思是，不仅是因为人们投射在她身上的东西。也许我们今天的嘉宾可以帮助我们剥离一些神话，还原真实的故事。是的，因为一个伟大的主题需要一位伟大的嘉宾。我们的嘉宾绝对当之无愧。她就是历史学家特蕾西·博曼（Tracey Borman），她撰写了一系列关于都铎王朝英格兰的广受好评的书籍。其中，与我们今天的主题密切相关的是《伊丽莎白的女性们：童贞女王的隐藏故事》（Elizabeth's Women: The Hidden Story of the Virgin Queen）。特蕾西，非常感谢你能加入我们。这是我的荣幸。虽然
I have to say I'm slightly reeling from Dominic referring to Elizabeth as second best. I'm not sure. I'm not sure what's going to happen. To James Callaghan. But to James Callaghan, come on. Tracy, everyone in history is second best to James Callaghan, according to Dominic. OK, fair enough. But not to Imagining History, who sent in a question to us, which I think is the perfect way to kick this off. And he or she says, chances are, if a person only knows of a few kings or queens, then Lizzie One will be on that list. There's countless books and films telling the tale of this monarch with no end in sight. So I'd like to know, what
我不得不说，多米尼克称伊丽莎白为“第二好”，我感到有些震惊。我不确定詹姆斯·卡拉汉会发生什么。但是詹姆斯·卡拉汉，拜托。特蕾西，根据多米尼克的说法，历史上的每个人都比不上詹姆斯·卡拉汉。好吧，有道理。但对于“想象历史”（Imagining History）来说并非如此，他给我们发来了一个问题，我认为这是开启这个话题的完美方式。他或她写道，如果一个人只知道几个国王或女王，那么“莉兹一世”（Lizzie One）很可能会在名单上。有无数的书籍和电影讲述这位君主的故事，而且似乎永无止境。所以我很想知道，
was it about Elizabeth I that has made her fame so enduring? And that's the big question, isn't it? It is. And you're asking somebody completely biased because Elizabeth is my all-time historical heroine. She's really where my love of history began. Well, I do think she deserves that place in history because she defied all the odds. By the time she came to the throne in 1558, it was seen as an absolute disaster for a woman to bear rule, as it was said. And there hadn't been very happy precedents before Elizabeth, but she changed all of that. She confounded the stereotype of a weak and feeble
伊丽莎白一世究竟有什么特质，使她的名声如此持久？这确实是个大问题，不是吗？确实。而且你问的是一个完全有偏见的人，因为伊丽莎白是我心目中永远的历史女英雄。我正是从她开始爱上历史的。嗯，我确实认为她在历史上占有一席之地，因为她克服了所有困难。到1558年她登上王位时，女性掌权被视为一场绝对的灾难。在伊丽莎白之前并没有什么令人愉快的先例，但她改变了这一切。她粉碎了柔弱女子的刻板印象。
woman. And her reign achieved greater stability than throughout the rest of the Tudor period. And I think it's one of history's greatest ironies that Henry VIII, her father, goes to all that trouble for a son. You know, he could have been content with his forgotten younger daughter, really. So Henry VIII, you know, obviously he's also a titanic figure in our imagination. He must have been a... Is he at the back of Elizabeth's mind the whole time? So she comes to the throne. She's had Mary, her sister, before her, Edward VI before her, and then above them all, kind of the daddy, Henry VIII. Is she trying to be another Henry VIII, do you think? Or is she trying to be the opposite? I think that's a really interesting question. Certainly,
她的统治实现了比整个都铎王朝其他时期更大的稳定性。我认为这是历史上最大的讽刺之一：她的父亲亨利八世为了一个儿子费尽周折。你知道，他本可以满足于他那个被遗忘的小女儿的。所以亨利八世，你知道，显然他在我们的想象中也是一个泰坦式的人物。他一定……他一直都在伊丽莎白的脑海里吗？所以她登上了王位。她之前有玛丽，她的姐姐，还有爱德华六世，然后凌驾于他们所有人之上，某种程度上是“老爸”亨利八世。你认为她是在试图成为另一个亨利八世吗？还是在试图成为他的对立面？我认为这是一个非常有趣的问题。当然，
Elizabeth publicly identifies with her father. So, you know, she calls herself the lion's cub, and she often refers to, well, that, you know, that wouldn't have happened in my father's time. So I think she does feel his presence, almost like he's there on her shoulder for a lot of her reign, particularly the early days. And it's like she's having to prove herself to her late father. But I think actually that's what she wanted people to identify her as, as the daughter of Henry VIII. Kind of gloss over the fact she's also the daughter of the scandalous Anne Boleyn. But when you look at her actions, not her words, you see how much actually she revered her late mother. The fact she promotes all her Boleyn relatives as soon as she's queen. She adopts her mother's emblem.
伊丽莎白公开认同她的父亲。所以，你知道，她称自己为“狮子幼崽”，她经常提到，嗯，那件事，你知道，在我父亲那个时代是不会发生的。所以我认为她确实感受到了他的存在，就像他在她统治的大部分时间里，尤其是在早期，一直站在她的肩膀上一样。这就像她必须向她已故的父亲证明自己。但我认为实际上这正是她希望人们认同她的身份——亨利八世的女儿。某种程度上掩盖了她也是那个声名狼藉的安妮·博林（Anne Boleyn）的女儿这一事实。但当你观察她的行动而非言语时，你会发现她实际上是多么崇敬她已故的母亲。她一成为女王就提拔了所有博林家族的亲戚。她采用了她母亲的徽章。
But she knows it's too controversial to talk too much about Anne Boleyn so the public face of Elizabeth and let's remember she's the master of PR is all about her father and Tracy Anne Boleyn is a Protestant and Mary her half-sister her predecessor of course is a Catholic and so this is the yin and yang, the pendulum swinging backwards and forwards through the 16th century. Did the fact that Anne Boleyn was Protestant mean that Elizabeth was always going to reject the Catholicism that Mary had tried to reintroduce? I think so. But also, Elizabeth was very influenced by her tutors in childhood, and they were all of a kind of reformist or Protestant bent, really.
但她知道谈论太多安妮·博林太具争议性，所以伊丽莎白的公众形象——让我们记住她是公关大师——完全是关于她父亲的。特蕾西，安妮·博林是新教徒，而她的前任、同父异母的姐姐玛丽当然是天主教徒，所以这就是阴阳，是16世纪来回摆动的钟摆。安妮·博林是新教徒这一事实是否意味着伊丽莎白注定要拒绝玛丽试图重新引入的天主教？我想是的。而且，伊丽莎白在童年时期深受她的导师们影响，他们都带有某种改革派或新教倾向。
And she also was very close to her half brother, Edward, the future Edward VI, who was probably an even more staunch Protestant than Elizabeth herself. So I think it was it was kind of a generational thing. Mary was much older than Elizabeth, 17 years older, and she was born very much into a Catholic world, whereas things by the time of Elizabeth's birth were very much beginning to change. So that absolutely shaped her worldview. How did Mary and Elizabeth get on? Did they really dislike each other? Well, on the face of it, we tend to think that they were at loggerheads from the beginning, but far from it. And I think Mary deserves credit because she had every reason to hate this child of the despised Anne Boleyn, who'd supplanted her own mother, Catherine of Aragon.
她和她同父异母的弟弟爱德华（未来的爱德华六世）也非常亲近，他可能比伊丽莎白本人更坚定地支持新教。所以我认为这是一种代际问题。玛丽比伊丽莎白大得多，大17岁，她出生在一个非常天主教的世界里，而伊丽莎白出生时，情况已经开始发生很大变化。所以这绝对塑造了她的世界观。玛丽和伊丽莎白相处得如何？她们真的互相讨厌吗？嗯，表面上看，我们倾向于认为她们从一开始就水火不容，但事实远非如此。我认为玛丽值得赞扬，因为她有充分的理由憎恨这个被鄙视的安妮·博林的女儿，是她取代了她自己的母亲阿拉贡的凯瑟琳。
But she seems to have felt sorry for the young Elizabeth after Anne Boleyn's execution. She kind of took her under her wing. And I think she had quite strong maternal instincts. It's quite tragic. Mary never had a child of her own. And so she really looked after Elizabeth and actually persuaded their father, Henry, to sort of forgive Elizabeth for Anne Boleyn's fate and everything that she'd done to him as he saw it. So the two sisters did grow up actually quite close. But then they were driven apart by this eternal issue of religion, particularly after Mary became queen. And that religious side of things, obviously, it's not just a sort of fig leaf.
但在安妮·博林被处决后，她似乎对年轻的伊丽莎白感到同情。她某种程度上把她带在身边照顾。我认为她有很强的母性本能。这很悲剧。玛丽从未有过自己的孩子。所以她确实照顾了伊丽莎白，并实际上说服了她们的父亲亨利，原谅伊丽莎白，不再计较安妮·博林的命运以及她在他眼中所做的一切。所以这对姐妹实际上是在相当亲近的环境中长大的。但后来她们被永恒的宗教问题分开了，特别是在玛丽成为女王之后。而宗教方面的事情，显然，这不仅仅是一块遮羞布。
It's not something that you – Elizabeth genuinely was a Protestant and she believes in it. But she sort of has to navigate it really. England has been torn apart. It's gone one way, then the other um she's a pragmatist right i mean she's sort of navigating through these very tricky kind of waters and actually the weird thing is that we've ended up with her church which is a kind of half catholic half protestant is that is that about right a half catholic half protestant yeah you've you've absolutely hit the nail on the head there dominicic, with the word pragmatist. That's what she was above everything else. Yes, she might have had quite strong beliefs
这不是某种你——伊丽莎白确实是一位新教徒，她信仰它。但她必须驾驭它。英格兰被撕裂了。它走了一条路，然后又走了另一条路。嗯，她是一个实用主义者，对吧？我的意思是，她是在这些非常棘手的水域中航行。实际上，奇怪的是，我们最终得到了她的教会，这是一种半天主教半新教的教会，这样说对吗？半天主教半新教，是的，你完全说到了点子上，多米尼克，用“实用主义者”这个词。她首先是这样的人。是的，她可能确实有相当坚定的信仰，
and she definitely veered more towards Protestantism than Catholicism, but she wanted compromise. She didn't want this issue of religion to continue to divide her people. So we have this wonderful compromise that is the Church of England. And if I may just put in a little pitch, because I always have to mention her, my favourite of the six wives, Anne of Cleves, I think it's she who taught Elizabeth the art of pragmatism. She'd given Henry his annulment. She'd seen what had happened to women who didn't do what Henry wanted. So she went with the flow, became arguably the most successful of Henry's wives. And Elizabeth became very influenced by Anne of Cleves and learned the art of pragmatism. Anne of Cleves lived the longest, didn't she?
而且她绝对比天主教更倾向于新教，但她想要妥协。她不希望宗教问题继续分裂她的人民。所以我们有了这种美妙的妥协，即英格兰国教会。如果我可以插一句，因为我总是要提到她，我最喜欢的六位王后之一，克里维斯的安妮（Anne of Cleves），我认为正是她教会了伊丽莎白实用主义的艺术。她给了亨利他想要的婚姻无效判决。她看到了那些不顺从亨利意愿的女性的下场。所以她顺势而为，成为了亨利所有妻子中最成功的一位。伊丽莎白深受克里维斯的安妮影响，并学会了实用主义的艺术。克里维斯的安妮活得最久，不是吗？
She did. She outlived all the rest. She lived well into Mary's reign. And I think it's really to her credit that she didn't fall out with anybody, Catholic, Protestant, whichever side of the royal divide you're on. Everybody liked her. Nobody had a bad word to say against Anne of Cleves. So I love her. She got given a lot of houses in Sussex. She did. They are now owned by the Sussex Archaeological Society, Britain's oldest county archaeological society, which is slightly short of cash. So anyone out there who would like to help them do do chip in and you'll be helping with a bit of history um but tracy i was about elizabeth i mean she's a pragmatist but she's also it seems to me and i i kind of recognize this trait because i
是的。她比其他所有人都活得久。她一直活到了玛丽统治时期。我认为她没有与任何人——无论是天主教徒、新教徒，无论你站在王室分裂的哪一边——发生冲突，这确实是她的功劳。每个人都喜欢她。没有人对克里维斯的安妮说过一句坏话。所以我爱她。她被赠予了萨塞克斯郡的许多房产。是的。它们现在由萨塞克斯考古协会拥有，这是英国最古老的县级考古协会，资金有些短缺。所以任何愿意帮助他们的人，请慷慨解囊，你将为历史贡献一份力量。嗯，但是特蕾西，我正想问伊丽莎白，我的意思是她是一个实用主义者，但她似乎也是——我某种程度上认同这个特质，因为我
kind of have it myself you're comparing yourself to the virgin queen yes i am sempre adem always the same basically she didn't like change very much did she and i'm feeling this very strong at the moment because my my i i went up for a zoom yesterday came down and found that my wife had completely re-wallpapered the uh the sitting room and i think that elizabeth the first would not have approved of that and i was kind of slightly startled by it as well and there's kind of sense in of sense in which her refusal to get rid, say, of the choirs in cathedrals and churches and things, which I'm very glad she didn't. But basically, she liked it, she didn't want to change it, so she's going to keep it no matter what the firebrand Protestants
我自己也有——你是在把自己比作童贞女王吗？是的，我是。Semper Eadem（永远如一），基本上她不太喜欢改变，不是吗？我现在对此感触很深，因为我昨天去参加了一个Zoom会议，下来发现我妻子完全重新贴了客厅的壁纸，我想伊丽莎白一世是不会赞同这一点的。我也对此感到有些吃惊。在某种意义上，她拒绝废除，比如说，大教堂和教堂里的唱诗班之类的东西，我很高兴她没有这样做。但基本上，她喜欢它，她不想改变它，所以无论那些激进的新教徒
wanted to do. I mean, that is also an aspect of her character, isn't it? It absolutely is. And I wonder, is this a historian's trait? Because I'm exactly the same. I hate change. I cannot abide it. And yeah, I think Elizabeth, certainly, you know, she had an appropriate motto. And I think even though she has gone down as a Protestant monarch, she did retain those bits of the Catholic faith that she'd always rather liked. And actually there's evidence she continued to hear Mass in private and she had Catholic friends, she had Catholic books in her collection. So she did sort of pick and choose a little bit. Let's get to what some people would consider the sort of the big question. I mean, when I say some people, not me, of course, but June or John on Twitter does consider this the big question. I mean, when I say some people, not me, of course, but June or John on Twitter does consider this the big question.
想要做什么，她都要保留它。我的意思是，这也是她性格的一个方面，不是吗？绝对是。我想知道，这是历史学家的特质吗？因为我完全一样。我讨厌改变。我无法忍受它。是的，我认为伊丽莎白，当然，你知道，她有一个恰当的座右铭。我认为尽管她被视为一位新教君主，但她确实保留了那些她一直相当喜欢的旧天主教信仰的片段。实际上有证据表明她继续私下听弥撒，她有天主教朋友，她的收藏中也有天主教书籍。所以她确实在某种程度上有所选择。让我们谈谈一些人会认为是“大问题”的事情。我的意思是，当我说是“一些人”时，当然不是我，但推特上的琼（June）或约翰（John）确实认为这是个大问题。
He or she says, of course, there's the debate as to whether she was really a virgin. Historians can't resist probing her private area. I think that's a man, Dominic. That's a man. I apologise for the question.
他或她说，当然，关于她是否真的是处女，存在着争论。历史学家无法抗拒探究她的私密领域。我想那是个男人，多米尼克。那是个男人。我为这个问题道歉。
I think that's actually Tom Holland who's asked that question. Absolutely not. Great respecter of the Virgin Queen's privacy. Do you know, I would be disappointed if I didn't get this question because every single talk I give, I'm asked this question. And when I say every single talk, even if the talk has been on something completely different, I once gave a lecture on Matilda of Flanders, the wife of
我想那实际上是汤姆·霍兰德（Tom Holland）问的问题。绝对不是。非常尊重童贞女王的隐私。你知道，如果我没有收到这个问题，我会感到失望的，因为我做的每一次演讲，都会被问到这个问题。当我说是“每一次演讲”时，即使演讲的主题完全不同。我曾经做过一场关于弗兰德斯的玛蒂尔达（Matilda of Flanders）的讲座，她是
William the Conqueror. And in the Q&A, the very first question was, so was Elizabeth really the virgin queen? Which I took offense at. But anyway, so my view is that she absolutely was. That's not to say she didn't dabble in various kind of flirtations and the like with her male favourites. But when you look at it, she had learned from the lessons of her past. There's no wonder she grew up terrified of marriage, of childbirth. She had no positive role models from her childhood and the female kind of influences of her early life. Her mother was executed at the orders of her father. One of her stepmothers was also executed. Her sister, Mary, had phantom pregnancies and
威廉征服者的妻子。在问答环节，第一个问题就是：那么，伊丽莎白真的是童贞女王吗？我对此感到冒犯。但无论如何，我的观点是她绝对是。这并不是说她没有与她的男性宠臣进行过各种调情之类的。但当你审视它时，她从过去的教训中吸取了经验。难怪她在恐惧婚姻、恐惧分娩中长大。她在童年时期和早年生活中没有积极的女性榜样。她的母亲在她父亲的命令下被处决。她的一位继母也被处决了。她的姐姐玛丽有过假孕，
suffered all that humiliation. So there's little wonder Elizabeth grew up thinking, okay, this just isn't for me. But politically as well, she didn't want to give any power away to a man. Now, there are rumours and there were rumours that she had affairs. Okay, she didn't want to marry, but she was still going to have sexual relationships. I don't believe she would ever have taken that risk because she knew the scandal it would visit on her and also, of course, the risk of pregnancy. But I think one of the most compelling pieces of evidence for Elizabeth's virginity came in 1562. Now, I'm going to get a plug in for where I should be right now, which is Hampton Court. This is my day job working for Historic Royal Palaces.
遭受了所有的羞辱。所以难怪伊丽莎白长大后认为，好吧，这不适合我。但在政治上，她也不想把任何权力交给男人。现在，有传言，而且当时也有传言说她有外遇。好吧，她不想结婚，但她仍然会有性关系。我不相信她会冒那个险，因为她知道这会给她带来丑闻，当然还有怀孕的风险。但我认为伊丽莎白保持童贞最令人信服的证据之一出现在1562年。现在，我要为我现在应该在的地方做个广告，那就是汉普顿宫。这是我的日常工作，为历史皇家宫殿工作。
And it's while staying at Hampton Court early in her reign that Elizabeth contracted smallpox, one of the deadliest diseases of the age. She almost died. She was so convinced she was going to die that she summoned her confessor. And she insisted that nothing improper had ever passed between her and her closest male favourite, Robert Dudley. Now you might say, okay, yeah, words are easy. Not in this God-fearing age. She would have thought that she was sacrificing her eternal salvation by telling a lie. So I do think she was the virgin. But, you know, she may have, as I say, dabbled. Isn't it true that Dudley had room?
正是在她统治初期住在汉普顿宫时，伊丽莎白感染了天花，这是那个时代最致命的疾病之一。她差点死了。她确信自己要死了，于是召见了她的忏悔神父。她坚持说，她和她最亲密的男性宠臣罗伯特·达德利（Robert Dudley）之间从未发生过任何不当行为。现在你可能会说，好吧，是的，说话很容易。在这个敬畏上帝的时代可不是这样。她会认为撒谎是在牺牲她永恒的救赎。所以我确实认为她是处女。但是，你知道，正如我所说，她可能“涉猎”过。达德利有房间不是真的吗？
She moved Dudley into a room next to her or something. Oh, yeah. And you don't think that, you know, in the dead of night? Or do you think what? Well, I mean, this is so prurient, isn't it? It reduces us to sort of people reading, you know, the sidebar of shame and Mail Online or something. No.
她把达德利搬到了她隔壁的房间还是什么的。哦，是的。你不认为，你知道，在深夜里？或者你认为什么？好吧，我的意思是，这太淫秽了，不是吗？这把我们降格为阅读，你知道，每日邮报在线版（Mail Online）的“羞耻侧边栏”之类的人。不。
But you genuinely don't think, you think she had, I suppose she had an iron self-control, didn't she? She did. And she would have exercised that in her private life as well as her political life. She absolutely did. And I think she'd inherited that self-control from her mother who kept Henry VIII at bay for seven years.
但你真的不认为，你认为她有，我想她有钢铁般的自制力，不是吗？她确实有。而且她在私生活中也会像在政治生活中一样行使这种自制力。她绝对做到了。我认为她从她母亲那里继承了那种自制力，她母亲让亨利八世保持了七年的距离。
So I do think she'd have exercised that. I think she certainly enjoyed Dudley's company, and absolutely she did things that were completely inappropriate in the eyes of her contemporaries, moving his rooms next to hers, tickling his collar when she conveyed an honour on him, and all sorts of things like that. But I don't think she ever went so far as to have a full sexual relationship with Dudley. I don't think she'd have taken the risk. Tracey, there's two other questions on this theme of Elizabeth's virginity. One from Christopher
所以我确实认为她会行使这种自制力。我认为她肯定享受达德利的陪伴，而且她绝对做过在同时代人眼中完全不恰当的事情，比如把他的房间搬到她隔壁，在她授予他荣誉时挠他的领子，以及诸如此类的各种事情。但我认为她从未走得那么远，与达德利发生过完整的性关系。我不认为她会冒那个险。特蕾西，关于伊丽莎白童贞这个主题还有两个问题。一个来自克里斯托弗·肯特（Christopher Kent）。
Kent. How much of the Virgin Queen persona was a reaction to the scandal with Thomas Seymour? So he was her guardian, wasn't he? And there was rumours perhaps of attempted rape. Absolutely. So could you give us the background on that? Because I think that's very interesting. It is interesting. So Thomas Seymour married Elizabeth's last stepmother, Catherine Parr, scandalously soon after Henry VIII's death. And Elizabeth loved Catherine Parr. So she sort of forgave her for this rather inappropriate, quick marriage. And she went to live with them. As you say, Seymour was sort of her guardian. And not long afterwards, rumours started about Seymour's
“童贞女王”的人设在多大程度上是对托马斯·西摩（Thomas Seymour）丑闻的反应？所以他是她的监护人，对吧？而且有传言说可能存在强奸未遂。绝对是。所以你能给我们讲讲背景吗？因为我认为这非常有趣。这确实很有趣。所以托马斯·西摩在亨利八世死后不久，就以令人震惊的速度娶了伊丽莎白的最后一位继母凯瑟琳·帕尔（Catherine Parr）。伊丽莎白爱凯瑟琳·帕尔。所以她某种程度上原谅了她这次相当不恰当、仓促的婚姻。她去和他们住在一起。正如你所说，西摩某种程度上是她的监护人。不久之后，关于西摩对十几岁的伊丽莎白的
behaviour towards the teenage Elizabeth. And it was absolutely out of order as behaviour goes. So he would go into Elizabeth's room early in the morning before she was up and dressed and sort of tickle her in bed. On another occasion, he cut her gown into a hundred pieces while Catherine Parr held Elizabeth down. You know, it's all deeply disturbing. That's pretty weird. It's really weird. I mean, you know, it has been called child abuse. And yet it's interesting how attitudes change, because this was always portrayed by historians as Elizabeth having this early flirtation. And it gave her a kind of taste for surrounding herself with admiring courtiers.
行为的传言就开始了。这种行为绝对是越界的。他会在清晨伊丽莎白起床穿衣之前进入她的房间，在床上挠她痒痒。另一次，他在凯瑟琳·帕尔按住伊丽莎白的情况下，把她的长袍剪成了一百块。你知道，这一切都令人深感不安。这太奇怪了。这真的很奇怪。我的意思是，你知道，这被称为虐待儿童。然而有趣的是人们的态度是如何改变的，因为这在历史上一直被历史学家描述为伊丽莎白早期的调情。这让她产生了一种被仰慕的朝臣包围的嗜好。
Whereas now, of course, we see it as much more disturbing. And I think rightly so. I think it did teach Elizabeth very valuable lessons. It probably confirmed her belief that really she just didn't want to go there when it came to marriage and relationships with men. But I think as well, it made her very protective of her relationship because this was incredibly damaging to her public image. And it was an absolute scandal, not just in England, but internationally, and it damaged her reputation as a potential bride. So I think this did make her really motivated to protect her reputation going forward. Right. Okay. And so following up on that,
而现在，当然，我们认为这更令人不安。我认为理应如此。我认为这确实给伊丽莎白上了非常宝贵的一课。这可能证实了她的信念，即在婚姻和男女关系方面，她真的不想涉足。但我认为同样，这让她对自己的关系非常保护，因为这对她的公众形象造成了极大的损害。这是一个绝对的丑闻，不仅在英格兰，而且在国际上，它损害了她作为潜在新娘的声誉。所以我认为这确实让她非常有动力在未来保护自己的声誉。好的。好的。那么接着这一点，
the way in which perhaps the virginity becomes the badge of her political responsibility. There's a question from Mim who asks, how aware and in personal control was she of her image? The replacement Virgin Mary stuff is well known, but the many direct comparisons to pagan deities are multiple and very skillful. So that's all kind of the climate that you get with Spencer and other poets. That is interesting, isn't it? It's really interesting. And I think Elizabeth was absolutely in control of her image. I mentioned she was a master of PR, really, as we would call it today.
童贞在某种程度上成为她政治责任的标志。米姆（Mim）问了一个问题，她对自己的形象有多大的意识和个人控制力？取代圣母玛利亚的东西是众所周知的，但许多与异教神灵的直接比较是多重且非常巧妙的。所以这都是斯宾塞（Spenser）和其他诗人所营造的那种氛围。这很有趣，不是吗？这真的很有趣。我认为伊丽莎白绝对掌控着自己的形象。我提到过她是公关大师，真的，就像我们今天所说的那样。
And she very carefully controlled her image in paintings with the so-called mask of youth where she never ages. And she also was instrumental in the crafting and the design of her public pageants and progresses. And she created this kind of world in which she was the unattainable kind of virgin in a court full of adoring men and advisors and ambassadors. And her attention to detail was quite extraordinary, all the way down to kind of obliging her ladies to kind of dress in sober colours so that her own glorious gowns were shown off to best effect. I love that. Do you think the idea that she fills a gap, the banishment of the Virgin with the banishment of Catholicism, do you think that's an idea that holds water? I think it is. And I think she publicly identified herself as a sort of Virgin Mary here on earth. And perhaps that's one of those remnants of Catholicism that actually she had quite cherished. but she became something to replace that.
她在绘画中非常小心地控制自己的形象，使用所谓的“青春面具”，让她永远不会变老。她还在她的公共庆典和巡游的设计中发挥了重要作用。她创造了一个世界，在这个世界里，她是宫廷中一群崇拜她的男人、顾问和大使中不可企及的童贞女。她对细节的关注非常非凡，甚至到了强迫她的女士们穿素色衣服，以便她自己华丽的长袍能展现出最佳效果的地步。我喜欢这一点。你认为她填补了一个空白，即随着天主教的放逐而放逐了圣母，你认为这个观点站得住脚吗？我认为是的。而且我认为她公开将自己定位为地球上的某种圣母玛利亚。也许这就是她实际上相当珍视的天主教残余之一。但她成为了某种东西来取代它。
And I think that was a real masterstroke. It was about worshipping her, not just obeying her, as all subjects are required to do. This kind of set her authority on a whole other footing. Tom, I can see Spanish ships ahead. I think we should take a break, play a game of bowls, get our troops together, and then we'll come back.
我认为这是一个真正的神来之笔。这是关于崇拜她，而不仅仅是服从她，正如所有臣民被要求做的那样。这在另一个层面上确立了她的权威。汤姆，我看到前面有西班牙船只。我想我们应该休息一下，玩一场滚球游戏，召集我们的部队，然后我们再回来。
And yes, we can ask Tracy some more questions. We'll see you our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Tom and I both have questions for Tracey Borman about Elizabeth I, but since I'm in control of the mic, I'm going to ask my question first. So, Tracey, the Spanish Armada, which is where we began the podcast, how much of a genuine threat to Elizabeth's crown and life
是的，我们可以问特蕾西更多问题。我们在会员俱乐部见。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和抢先购买现场票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余味》。汤姆和我都有关于伊丽莎白一世的问题要问特蕾西·博曼，但既然麦克风在我手里，我要先问我的问题。所以，特蕾西，西班牙无敌舰队，也就是我们开始播客的地方，你认为它对伊丽莎白的王位和生命构成了多大的真正威胁，
do you think it was, and how much credit should we give her, rather than her captains for or indeed the weather for seeing off Philip II so I think the Armada was the greatest threat that not just Elizabeth but England had faced uh really for many years now on its own uh Philip II assembling a fleet in Spain and setting sail, that fleet was actually pretty well matched with Elizabeth's navy. But the key factor here was that the Spanish armada was going to unite with the Duke of Parma's ships and the Duke of Parma's forces, which were stationed in the Netherlands, perilously close to England.
我们应该给她多少功劳，而不是给她的船长们，或者甚至是天气，来归功于击退了腓力二世？所以我认为无敌舰队不仅是伊丽莎白，也是英格兰多年来面临的最大威胁。现在，腓力二世在西班牙集结了一支舰队并起航，那支舰队实际上与伊丽莎白的海军旗鼓相当。但这里的关键因素是，西班牙无敌舰队将与帕尔马公爵（Duke of Parma）的船只以及驻扎在荷兰、离英格兰危险地近的帕尔马公爵的军队会合。
Now, if that rendezvous had happened successfully, I think the Armada was pretty much unbeatable. But it didn't. And then there was a series of catastrophes, not least the weather. But I think we have to give some credit to Elizabeth's commanders, Lord Howard and the other members of her navy, such as it was in those days, because they were very skilled sailors and they were very skilled tacticians as well. And the use of fire ships was quite instrumental. But I have to say that all of that considered, if it hadn't been for the good old british weather deciding the day then i'm not sure the armada really would have been elizabeth's finest hour but but tracy if they'd if it had worked right if they'd got you know if they if they'd got control of the channel if they got the troops over into england i mean would that have been curtains for elizabeth i mean would it have been an appointment with a chopping block or would she been off to a convent or you know what was the what was the future for her yeah i or would she have been off to a convent? What was the future
现在，如果那次会合成功了，我认为无敌舰队几乎是不可战胜的。但它没有。然后发生了一系列灾难，尤其是天气。但我认为我们必须给伊丽莎白的指挥官们，霍华德勋爵（Lord Howard）和她海军的其他成员，以应有的赞誉，因为他们是非常熟练的水手，也是非常熟练的战术家。火船的使用相当关键。但我必须说，考虑到所有这些，如果不是因为老天爷决定了那一天，那么我不确定无敌舰队是否真的是伊丽莎白最辉煌的时刻。但是，特蕾西，如果他们成功了呢？如果他们控制了海峡，如果他们把军队送到了英格兰，我的意思是，那对伊丽莎白来说是不是就完了？我的意思是，那会是去断头台的预约，还是她会被送进修道院，或者你知道，她的未来是什么？
for her? Yeah, I think it would have been curtains for Elizabeth because Philip II couldn't have allowed her to live really and establish his own authority. I mean, could he have married her or married her to one of his family? Possibly, but I think she would always have been seen as too great a threat. So I think it would have been the end of Elizabeth's life. Whether, in fact, there would have been enough resistance and coordinated resistance to eject Spain and install another English or probably Scottish monarch in Philip II's place is a bit more debatable. But no, this was absolute peril for Elizabeth and the entire Tudor dynasty. Because the thing about Tilbury is basically it was dad's army, wasn't it? And the Spanish troops on the other side are kind of the most lethal killing machine in Europe.
是的，我认为对伊丽莎白来说就完了，因为腓力二世不可能允许她活着并建立他自己的权威。我的意思是，他能娶她或者把她嫁给他的家人吗？有可能，但我认为她总是会被视为太大的威胁。所以我认为那将是伊丽莎白生命的终结。至于实际上是否会有足够的抵抗和协调一致的抵抗来驱逐西班牙并在腓力二世的位置上安装另一位英格兰或可能是苏格兰的君主，这还有待商榷。但不，这对伊丽莎白和整个都铎王朝来说是绝对的危险。因为关于提尔伯里的事情基本上是“爸爸的军队”（Dad's Army），不是吗？而另一边的西班牙军队是欧洲最致命的杀人机器。
So it really, if they had crossed, it would have all been over. Yeah. There's more than a whiff of Dad's Army about all of this. But by the time that Elizabeth delivered that iconic speech, and let's give her credit for that speech of all of her many public addresses, that was the best, I think. By the time she was at Tilbury saying all those amazing, inspiring words to her troops, the danger had pretty much passed. Yeah, but she didn't know that, did she, by that point?
所以真的，如果他们跨过来了，一切就都结束了。是的。这一切中确实有一种“爸爸的军队”的味道。但在伊丽莎白发表那篇标志性演讲时——让我们为那篇演讲给她点赞，在她所有的许多公开演讲中，我认为那是最好的一篇——当她在提尔伯里对她的部队说出所有那些令人惊叹、鼓舞人心的话时，危险基本上已经过去了。是的，但她当时不知道，不是吗？
Is that fair? I can't believe that you're defending her and I'm sort of speaking against her. It should be the other way around, actually. But no, you're right. Probably communications being as it were, she wasn't that aware. It was still a very brave thing for her to do. But, Tracy, if I can jump in, Tom knows I like to be sceptical. That speech, I mean, how do we know that she actually said any of those words?
这样说公平吗？我不敢相信你在为她辩护，而我却在某种程度上反对她。实际上应该是反过来的。但不，你是对的。通信状况如此，她并没有那么清楚。这对她来说仍然是一件非常勇敢的事情。但是，特蕾西，如果我可以插一句，汤姆知道我喜欢怀疑。那篇演讲，我的意思是，我们怎么知道她真的说了那些话？
Are those not just words put in her mouth by a chronicler or something? Well, the thing is, in Elizabeth's defence, and I think we can be pretty certain about this, there wasn't just one account of that speech. There were several written by people who were there. Now, they don't exactly match up, but it's close enough, particularly with certain lines. So I think... I want to believe it. I want to believe it as much as anybody. Yes, absolutely.
那些难道不是编年史家之类的放在她嘴里的话吗？嗯，问题是，为伊丽莎白辩护，我认为我们可以相当确定这一点，关于那篇演讲不仅仅有一个版本。有几个版本是由当时在场的人写的。现在，它们并不完全吻合，但已经足够接近了，特别是在某些台词上。所以我认为……我想相信它。我想像任何人一样相信它。是的，绝对。
One of the reasons for thinking that Elizabeth said that was that she was a great writer. I mean, she was a very, very literate person. And of course, this is the great age of English literature. So the Spanish Armada percolates through into the writings of the poets. It's there in Shakespeare, come the three corners of the world in arms and we shall shock them. To what extent do you think Elizabeth plays a role as the kind of presiding genius of that literary renaissance. And also kind of a matching question, to what extent do you think the genius of that writing then reflects back on the perspective that we have on Elizabeth? I think there is a temptation, and I've fallen prey to this, to give Elizabeth credit for
认为伊丽莎白说了那些话的原因之一是她是一位伟大的作家。我的意思是，她是一个非常有文化的人。当然，这是英国文学的伟大时代。所以西班牙无敌舰队渗透到了诗人的作品中。它存在于莎士比亚的作品中：“当世界的三方联合起来武装进攻时，我们将震慑他们。”你认为伊丽莎白在那种文学复兴中扮演了什么样的 presiding genius（主导天才）角色？还有一个对应的问题，你认为那种写作的天才在多大程度上反过来影响了我们对伊丽莎白的看法？我认为有一种诱惑，我也曾深受其害，那就是把伊丽莎白归功于
everything that happened in this glorious kind of Elizabethan flowering of culture and the arts. But I do think that she was a great patron of the arts. I mean, we know that she attended plays by Shakespeare. Obviously, Edmund Spencer was a big favourite as well. So she was an active participant and promoter of the arts. But arguably, there were other influences at play here too. The stability of the regime and of the kingdom that she had helped to establish certainly did promote this flowering of the arts and of literature. And the fact that we were getting influences in from all corners of the globe during the later 16th century. I think that was very profound as well in terms of the kind of
在这个辉煌的伊丽莎白时代的文化和艺术繁荣中发生的一切。但我确实认为她是一位伟大的艺术赞助人。我的意思是，我们知道她参加过莎士比亚的戏剧。显然，埃德蒙·斯宾塞（Edmund Spencer）也是她的最爱。所以她是一位积极的参与者和艺术推动者。但可以说，这里还有其他影响在起作用。她帮助建立的政权和王国的稳定性确实促进了艺术和文学的繁荣。而且我们在16世纪后期从全球各个角落获得影响的事实。我认为这在艺术的发展方面也非常深远。
development of the arts. But people followed Elizabeth's lead. She was going to the theatre, she was reading all of these plays and patronising all of these artists and authors and playwrights. And so the great and the good of England at the time absolutely went where Elizabeth followed. And that's why you get sort of the funding for the arts, if you like, if you put it in modern terms, that we see during Elizabeth's reign. But there's another side to Elizabeth's England, isn't there, Tracy,
但人们追随伊丽莎白的脚步。她去剧院，她阅读所有这些戏剧，并赞助所有这些艺术家、作家和剧作家。所以当时英格兰的显贵们绝对追随伊丽莎白。这就是为什么你会得到艺术资金，如果你用现代术语来说的话，我们在伊丽莎白统治时期看到了这一点。但伊丽莎白的英格兰还有另一面，不是吗，特蕾西？
which Nick Brown has asked a question about on Twitter. And he wants to know about the Burghley-Walsingham surveillance state. And he says, you know, did ordinary citizens feel they had to watch what they said? And there are books like Stephen Alford's book, The Watchers and stuff. You know, this sort of image of Elizabeth in England where she's basically a sort of lunatic with a wig. And, you know, the public are kind of living in fear that, you know,
尼克·布朗（Nick Brown）在推特上问了一个关于这个问题的问题。他想了解伯利-沃尔辛厄姆（Burghley-Walsingham）的监视国家。他说，你知道，普通公民是否觉得他们必须注意自己的言行？有像斯蒂芬·阿尔福德（Stephen Alford）的书《守望者》（The Watchers）之类的书。你知道，这种伊丽莎白时代的英格兰形象，她基本上是一个戴着假发的疯子。而且，你知道，公众生活在恐惧中，担心，你知道，
there's spies everywhere there's paranoia and conspiracies and and it's just this sort of you know this sort of elizabethan east germany is there any you know how do you how do you respond to all that do you think there's a bit of truth in all that um there's certainly truth in the sophistication of the spy networks that uh walsingham and and to a lesser extent, Burley helped to establish. And by the way, I'm a huge fan of Stephen Olsen's book, and I keep recommending it to people. It's amazing. And a real eye-opener to just what went into stabilising the Elizabethan regime. And the fact it isn't just Elizabeth there making her great speeches and these memorable
到处都是间谍，有偏执和阴谋，这只是某种，你知道，这种伊丽莎白时代的东德。有什么，你知道，你如何回应这一切？你认为这一切中有一点真实吗？嗯，沃尔辛厄姆（Walsingham）和在较小程度上伯利（Burley）帮助建立的间谍网络的复杂性确实是真实的。顺便说一句，我是斯蒂芬·阿尔福德书的忠实粉丝，我一直在向人们推荐它。这太棒了。真正让人大开眼界，了解稳定伊丽莎白政权需要付出什么。而且事实不仅仅是伊丽莎白在那里发表她的伟大演讲和这些令人难忘的
public appearances. There's a whole lot that went into keeping her on her throne. And I think it's incredibly impressive, the communication channels that Walsingham managed to open up across the world, not just in England. But I think it goes too far to say that Elizabeth is some kind of ineffectual puppet at the head of all of this, just a sort of figurehead, and that she isn't kind of pulling her own strings, as I believe she was. And I think you see from the descriptions of the council meetings, of the parliaments that she attended, of her correspondence with her ministers, just how much she is personally involved, how much she is shaping and to a certain extent dictating
公开露面。为了让她坐在王位上，付出了很多努力。我认为沃尔辛厄姆设法在世界各地，而不仅仅是在英格兰，建立的通信渠道令人印象深刻。但我认为说伊丽莎白是这一切之首的某种无效傀儡，只是某种挂名首脑，而她没有在某种程度上操纵自己的线，这有点过分了，我相信她是这样做的。我认为从对议会会议、她参加的议会、她与大臣们的通信的描述中，你可以看出她个人参与了多少，她在多大程度上塑造并在一定程度上决定了
affairs. But I think one of Elizabeth's greatest gifts is that she did take advice. She didn't quite have the same ego as her father, who liked to pretend that he was the one solely in charge, coming up with all the ideas when really it's the likes of Thomas Cromwell and Wolsey working behind the scenes. Whereas Elizabeth, she very publicly did depend on advisors such as William Cecil, Lord Burley. I mean, to follow up on that, the darkness that one could see in Elizabethan England, because this is a time of potential terrorist threats, pandemics, recession, isolation from Europe. There are certain parallels there. And I guess the kind of, you know, when I think of Elizabethan England,
事务。但我认为伊丽莎白最大的天赋之一是她确实听取了建议。她不像她父亲那样有那么大的自我，他喜欢假装自己是唯一负责的人，想出所有的主意，而实际上是托马斯·克伦威尔（Thomas Cromwell）和沃尔西（Wolsey）在幕后工作。而伊丽莎白，她非常公开地依赖威廉·塞西尔（William Cecil）、伯利勋爵（Lord Burley）这样的顾问。我的意思是，接着这一点，人们在伊丽莎白时代的英格兰可以看到的黑暗，因为这是一个潜在的恐怖威胁、流行病、经济衰退、与欧洲隔绝的时代。这其中有一些相似之处。我想，当我想到伊丽莎白时代的英格兰时，
I always think of blue skies and, yes, Elizabeth's procession through, you know, merry England and people dancing around maypoles. But of course, the reality must have been grimmer and darker, particularly if you're Catholic, but also for lots of people struggling to make a living in what economically were quite difficult times. And you say, you know, the impact of plague on Elizabethan England.
我总是想到蓝天，是的，伊丽莎白穿过，你知道，快乐的英格兰，人们在五朔节花柱周围跳舞。但当然，现实一定是更严酷、更黑暗的，特别是如果你是天主教徒，而且对于许多在经济上相当困难的时期努力维持生计的人来说也是如此。你说，你知道，瘟疫对伊丽莎白时代英格兰的影响。
Obviously, you have a profounder sense of it now than perhaps we might have had, you know, a year and a half ago. I know the contemporary parallels really are very striking. I think throughout the Tudor period, I was asked, oh, about four and a half years ago, to write a piece for a national newspaper that I won't name, on was Henry VIII responsible for Brexit? Oh, yeah, David Starkey did that piece.
显然，你现在比我们一年半前可能有的感觉更深刻。我知道当代的相似之处确实非常引人注目。我认为在整个都铎王朝时期，我被问到，哦，大约四年半前，为一家我不愿透露名字的全国性报纸写一篇文章，关于亨利八世是否对脱欧负责？哦，是的，大卫·斯塔基（David Starkey）写过那篇文章。
Yes, there you go. I think I've done that piece. Oh, okay. Well, I decided not to go there. There you go. That's how little I like controversy, Dominic, but obviously you're braver than me. But there were parallels, certainly.
是的，就是这样。我想我写过那篇文章。哦，好吧。嗯，我决定不去碰那个。你看，这就是我有多不喜欢争议，多米尼克，但显然你比我勇敢。但确实有相似之处。
And I think there is a darker side, undoubtedly, to Elizabethan England, and particularly as the reign progresses and as the succession becomes more of an issue, because of course we have the Virgin Queen. She's not going to leave any direct descendants. And that's when really there is nervousness about the future. And there is an increasing threat from the Catholic community, both within and outside England.
我认为伊丽莎白时代的英格兰无疑有着黑暗的一面，特别是在统治后期，随着继承权问题日益凸显，因为我们都知道“童贞女王”不会留下任何直系后代。那时人们对未来感到非常不安。来自英格兰内外天主教团体的威胁也日益增加。
Now, as part of my work for Historic Royal Palaces, I am at the Tower of London a lot. And I think it's striking to look at the physical evidence for this sort of darkness that descended in Elizabeth's later years. And that comes from the Beecham Tower inside the Tower of London, where you see the evidence of graffiti left behind in the sort of 1580s, 1590s by all of the Catholic prisoners who were kept there under suspicion of plotting Elizabeth's assassination. So let's remember the Pope had sanctioned it. He'd encouraged the people of the faith to actually murder their queen. And you really see that chiseled into the stone of the Beecham Tower inside the Tower of London. I think most people who visit the tower tend to make a beeline for the crown jewels.
作为“历史皇家宫殿”工作的一部分，我经常去伦敦塔。我认为，审视伊丽莎白晚年那种黑暗氛围的实物证据是非常震撼的。这些证据来自伦敦塔内的比彻姆塔，在那里你可以看到16世纪80年代和90年代被关押在那里的天主教囚犯留下的涂鸦，他们因涉嫌策划暗杀伊丽莎白而被囚禁。我们要记住，教皇曾批准过这种行为。他鼓励信徒们去谋杀他们的女王。你真的可以在伦敦塔内比彻姆塔的石头上看到这些刻痕。我认为大多数参观伦敦塔的人往往直奔王冠珠宝而去。
But I'd like to just put in a pitch for the Beecham Tower. It's really very chilling. Tracey, given how much stability mattered to Elizabeth and how much the question of, I mean, the Tudor dynasty is a new dynasty. You know, it's only been there since 1485. And given how much it obviously and understandably mattered to her father, it seems odd that the succession is kind of that question is just hanging there the whole time, because you'd think succession planning would be the number one priority. So, for example, Paul Bernardi on Twitter says, why do you think she left that in doubt for so long?
但我还是想为比彻姆塔说几句。它真的让人不寒而栗。特蕾西，考虑到稳定性对伊丽莎白有多重要，考虑到都铎王朝是一个新王朝——你知道，它从1485年才开始——而且考虑到这对她父亲来说显然且理所当然地非常重要，继承权问题一直悬而未决似乎很奇怪，因为你会认为继承规划应该是头等大事。例如，推特上的保罗·伯纳迪问，你认为她为什么让这个问题悬而未决这么久？
Is that a kind of egotism almost, that she can't conceive of anybody other than herself as monarch? in shaping her view because when her sister Mary was dying, people started to flock to Elizabeth as being the most likely heir and they completely shifted their focus away from Mary. And certainly, all of the eyes were on the future queen, not on the present queen. And I think it's not just egotism. I think Elizabeth wanted to retain control and she didn't want to name her successor too early. She gave hints, but she never went so far as to confirm that it would be the King of Scots, James VI, who was her closest blood relative. Although her father, Henry VIII, had actually barred his Scottish descendants we tend to overlook that fact and it doesn't bother her Tracy that it's not going to be a Tudor I mean if it bothered Henry
这是否近乎一种自负，让她无法想象除了自己以外还有谁能担任君主？这在塑造她的观点时起到了作用，因为当她的姐姐玛丽病重时，人们开始涌向伊丽莎白，认为她是最大的继承人，他们完全将注意力从玛丽身上转移开了。当然，所有的目光都集中在未来的女王身上，而不是现任女王身上。我认为这不仅仅是自负。我认为伊丽莎白想保持控制权，她不想太早指定继任者。她给过暗示，但从未明确表示会是她最近的血亲——苏格兰国王詹姆斯六世。尽管她的父亲亨利八世实际上已经排除了他的苏格兰后裔，我们往往忽略了这一事实。特蕾西，如果那不是都铎王朝的血脉，她不介意吗？我的意思是，如果亨利介意的话
so much it had to be a Tudor of course because his own father won the crown on the battlefield why doesn't that bother Elizabeth that the dynasty is going to come to an end so quickly I think it does bother her but I think the sticking point with Elizabeth is marriage. And I think this really, of course, is why the whole succession is thrown into doubt, because Elizabeth is faced with this kind of impossible choice between marrying and leaving direct heirs, but then either ceding her authority to a husband, and she made that famous remark, I will have but one mistress here and no master. But also, who do you choose as a husband? If you choose an Englishman, it divides the court.
那他肯定会坚持必须是都铎王朝的人，毕竟他自己的父亲是在战场上赢得的王冠。为什么伊丽莎白不介意王朝这么快就终结呢？我认为她确实介意，但我认为伊丽莎白的症结在于婚姻。我认为这当然就是整个继承权问题陷入困境的原因，因为伊丽莎白面临着一种不可能的选择：要么结婚并留下直系后代，但随后要么将权力让给丈夫——她曾说过那句名言：“我在这里只会有一位女主人，而没有男主人。”但问题是，你选谁做丈夫？如果你选一个英国人，这会分裂朝廷。
It kind of creates these factions. If you choose a foreigner, well, look how that went for her sister, Mary. And she once remarked, the English hate foreigners, so I can't marry a foreign prince. They are, Elizabeth was. And so she had this impossible choice. There isn't a good option here or an easy option. So that's why she decides not to marry. And of course, that's why the succession becomes such a hot potato, particularly in her later reign. But I mean, I'm surprised because I thought that essentially it's a hot potato while Mary Queen of
这会制造派系。如果你选一个外国人，看看她姐姐玛丽的下场就知道了。她曾说，英国人讨厌外国人，所以我不能嫁给外国王子。伊丽莎白就是这样。所以她面临着这种不可能的选择。这里没有好的选择，也没有容易的选择。这就是为什么她决定不结婚。当然，这就是为什么继承权问题变得如此棘手，特别是在她统治的后期。但我的意思是，我很惊讶，因为我以为这基本上是在玛丽女王在世时才是个棘手的问题。
Scots is alive. And essentially the elimination of Mary Queen of Scots makes it less of a hot potato because then the heir is a Protestant. As long as you've got Mary Queen of Scots as a potential figurehead for Catholic conspirators and she's going to succeed if Elizabeth dies, that's the real hot potato. Is that not right? Yeah, no, there is an element of truth to that but there were other contenders um as well and notably our bella stewart um who her blood line was slightly weaker than james's but she had been born on english soil so actually she was a favorite among um many members of elizabeth's courts um but sadly our bella kind of upset uh elizabeth when they were introduced, when she visited court as a teenager and she was very haughty, Elizabeth Court. And then she kind of seemed to lose it and
苏格兰女王在世时，这确实是个棘手的问题。而苏格兰女王玛丽的被除掉，基本上让这个问题不再那么棘手，因为继承人变成了新教徒。只要苏格兰女王玛丽还是天主教阴谋家的潜在领袖，而且如果伊丽莎白去世她就会继位，那才是真正的棘手问题。难道不是吗？是的，这确实有一定道理，但还有其他竞争者，特别是阿拉贝拉·斯图尔特。她的血统比詹姆斯的稍微弱一点，但她出生在英国本土，所以实际上她是伊丽莎白朝廷中许多人青睐的对象。但遗憾的是，阿拉贝拉在十几岁时访问朝廷并被介绍给伊丽莎白时，表现得非常傲慢，惹恼了伊丽莎白。然后她似乎就失宠了，并且
was described as sort of half mad by the time the succession really became a pressing issue. So she almost wrote herself out of the story. So I think Elizabeth probably knew for many years it was going to be James who succeeded her. But it was literally just on her deathbed when finally, you know, her ministers are gathered around her bedside. You say, will it be the King of Scots, ma'am? And she draws a kind of coronet over her head because she's beyond speech. And that was said to have signalled her assent that yes, it's the King of Scots who will now be the King of England too. Tracy, on the subject of Mary Queen of Scots who will now be the King of England too. Tracey, on the subject of Mary Queen of Scots, we've got one from the aptly named Khaleesi,
在继承权真正成为紧迫问题时，她被描述为半疯。所以她几乎把自己从这个故事中写出局了。所以我认为伊丽莎白可能多年来一直知道继位者会是詹姆斯。但直到她临终时，当大臣们聚集在床边时，他们问：“会是苏格兰国王吗，陛下？”她把手放在头上比划了一个冠冕的动作，因为她已经无法说话了。据说这标志着她的默许，是的，苏格兰国王现在也将成为英格兰国王。特蕾西，关于苏格兰女王玛丽的话题，我们有一个来自名字很贴切的卡丽熙的问题，
who asks, did Elizabeth know that William Cecil was going to have Mary Queen of Scots executed? And I guess that that, along with the virginity question, is the, you know, it's the big unknown, isn't it? Yeah. Although, you know, much as I love Elizabeth, she was laying on thick when it came to her reaction to Mary Queen of Scots execution. She knew full well, she sanctioned it, she knew exactly what she was signing with the execution warrant when it was presented to her by her secretary, William Davison. They actually discussed it. And poor old Davison, you know, became a scapegoat afterwards. But Elizabeth was trying desperately to distance herself from Mary's execution because she feared the wrath of Catholic Europe. She feared the wrath of Mary's son, James, although actually he was remarkably
她问，伊丽莎白是否知道威廉·塞西尔要处决苏格兰女王玛丽？我想，这和童贞问题一样，是一个巨大的未知数，不是吗？是的。虽然，你知道，尽管我很喜欢伊丽莎白，但她在对玛丽女王被处决的反应上确实演得太过了。她非常清楚，她批准了处决，当她的秘书威廉·戴维森把处决令呈给她时，她完全知道自己在签什么。他们实际上讨论过这件事。可怜的戴维森后来成了替罪羊。但伊丽莎白拼命想让自己与玛丽的处决保持距离，因为她害怕天主教欧洲的愤怒。她害怕玛丽的儿子詹姆斯的愤怒，尽管实际上他非常
quick to forgive Elizabeth for beheading his mother. So I think it's all pure play acting on Elizabeth's part. This, oh, I didn't realise what I'd signed. I didn't want them to take the warrant up there. And it's like, come on, pull the other one, Elizabeth. But that's clever monarchical leadership, isn't it? You take responsibility for the good and you pretend that your advisors are responsible for the bad. Exactly. So, Tracey, here's a question for you. There have been innumerable screen Elizabeths,
快就原谅了伊丽莎白斩首他的母亲。所以我认为这完全是伊丽莎白在演戏。什么“我不知道我签了什么”、“我不想让他们把处决令带过去”。这简直是，得了吧，别骗人了，伊丽莎白。但这正是高明的君主领导力，不是吗？你为好事承担责任，而假装你的顾问要为坏事负责。正是如此。那么，特蕾西，这里有个问题问你。银幕上有无数的伊丽莎白，
you know, Cate Blanchett, Judi Dench, you name it. Who are the best and worst? Ha, yes, and I've watched them all because I'm obsessed. The very first talk I gave ever when I was, you know, kind of a fledgling historian was film representations of Elizabeth. So I've done my research on this. And do you know what I concluded for that? And my view is still the same, that it's Miranda Richardson's Blackadder portrayal that is my favourite.
你知道，凯特·布兰切特、朱迪·丹奇等等。谁是最好和最差的？哈，是的，我全都看过，因为我对此很着迷。我还是个初出茅庐的历史学家时，做的第一次演讲就是关于伊丽莎白的电影形象。所以我对此做过研究。你知道我得出的结论是什么吗？我的观点依然没变，那就是米兰达·理查森在《黑爵士》中的表演是我的最爱。
It's the best. She absolutely nails it in terms of Elizabeth's kind of, you know, fickle behaviour, unpredictability, vanity. But you love her anyway. And the worst? Oh, the worst. I don't know. You see, I'm a bit of a fan of the Cate Blanchett portrayal,
那是最好的。她完全抓住了伊丽莎白那种反复无常、不可预测、虚荣的特点。但你还是会爱上她。那最差的呢？哦，最差的。我不知道。你看，我是凯特·布兰切特表演的粉丝，
and I shouldn't name that because, you know, hopefully as a credible historian, I'm not saying it's an accurate film. I just quite liked her portrayal. I have to say I can't probably claim that this is the worst because I haven't seen it, but you know, the latest film about Mary, Queen of Scots, and I saw bits of that. Margot Robbie.
我不应该提这个，因为你知道，作为一个有信誉的历史学家，我不能说这是一部准确的电影。我只是很喜欢她的表演。我必须说，我可能不能断言这是最差的，因为我还没看过，但你知道，关于苏格兰女王玛丽的最新电影，我看了片段。玛格特·罗比。
Margot Robbie is in it. Oh, I thought she was quite good in that. Really? Are you just judging on looks, Tom? Are you just judging on looks? It was striking. She had a strong look. A strong look.
玛格特·罗比在里面。哦，我觉得她在里面演得挺好的。真的吗？汤姆，你只是在看颜值吗？你只是在看颜值吗？这很引人注目。她有一种强烈的气质。一种强烈的气质。
She had a strong look. I think, you know the just looking at the trailers for that made me cross because Mary Queen of Scots is always hailed as this great tragic heroine I think she was just a bit stupid
她有一种强烈的气质。我认为，光看预告片就让我很生气，因为苏格兰女王玛丽总是被誉为伟大的悲剧女主角，我觉得她其实有点蠢。
and I I once wrote a piece for a BBC history magazine about was Mary Queen of Scots the most overrated person in history
我曾经为BBC历史杂志写过一篇文章，题目是“苏格兰女王玛丽是历史上被高估最多的人吗？”
and I argued that yes she was overrated person in all history that's a brave piece in all of history it's a bold claim, Dominic. I did that and chose Henry V.
我论证了是的，她是历史上被高估最多的人。那是一篇勇敢的文章。在整个历史上，这是一个大胆的断言，多米尼克。我做了那个，还选了亨利五世。
Oh, did you? Yeah, I did. Oh, God. Yeah. This is a podcast in and of itself, isn't it? I think that would be a good topic, wouldn't it, Dominic? I think it would be a good topic. People overrated.
哦，你选了吗？是的，我选了。哦，天哪。是的。这本身就是一个播客主题，不是吗？我觉得那会是个很好的话题，不是吗，多米尼克？我觉得那会是个很好的话题。人们被高估了。
But I tell you, an actress who stays in my mind rather oddly is Anita Dobson. Oh, yes. In the Armada series. Yes. Yes. And it was a BBC drama about the Armada. And I think it featured Dan Snow storming around on boats looking Danish. But that actually had a counterfactual where the Spanish succeed and they arrest her and she gets carried off to prison
但我告诉你，有一位女演员让我印象深刻，虽然有点奇怪，那就是安妮塔·多布森。哦，是的。在《无敌舰队》系列里。是的。是的。那是一部关于无敌舰队的BBC剧集。我想里面还有丹·斯诺在船上横冲直撞，看起来很像丹麦人。但那实际上有一个反事实的情节，西班牙人成功了，他们逮捕了她，她被带走关进监狱，
and she loses all her wig and she's got kind of no teeth and things. Does Leslie Grantham play Philip II? Do you know, I'm so pleased. I am so pleased you raised this, Tom, because one of my greatest claims to fame, so I was talking head in that series, and so I was invited to the kind of you know the airing of it what have you what do you call those the premiere i don't know screening
她失去了所有的假发，看起来没牙什么的。是莱斯利·格兰瑟姆扮演腓力二世吗？你知道，我很高兴你提到了这一点，汤姆，因为我最引以为傲的事情之一就是，我是那个系列的访谈嘉宾，所以我被邀请参加了那个……你知道，首映式，或者叫什么来着？预览。
the preview thank you the preview the preview and uh anita dobson was there and i was sitting behind her and brian may and for that reason i couldn't see the screen because of brian may's hair so because it was so big. And so, you know. It was Elizabethan wig. Who was Brian May playing? Frances Strickland. Yeah, exactly.
预览，谢谢，预览。预览的时候，安妮塔·多布森也在场，我坐在她和布莱恩·梅后面，因为布莱恩·梅的头发太大了，我看不见屏幕。所以，你知道。那是伊丽莎白时代的假发。布莱恩·梅扮演谁？弗朗西斯·斯特里克兰。是的，没错。
That kind of thing. But I thought, yeah, that was just, I was just completely starstruck. But yeah, certainly I'd forgotten about Anita Dobson's portrayal. That was an interesting choice as a casting. So Tracy, we did a World Cup of Prime Ministers, which I'm sure you followed very closely when it was on. If we had a World Cup of English monarchs, do you think Elizabeth would make the final? Oh, she'd be there. She'd be holding aloft the trophy. I think, you know,
就是那种。但我当时想，我完全被明星光环震住了。但确实，我忘了安妮塔·多布森的表演了。那是一个有趣的选角选择。那么特蕾西，我们做过一个首相世界杯，我相信你当时一定密切关注过。如果我们举办一个英格兰君主世界杯，你认为伊丽莎白能进决赛吗？哦，她肯定会在。她会高举奖杯。我认为，你知道，
this is quite a pertinent question. This is going to sound like I'm doing a shameless plug now, isn't it? But I have just put the finishing touches to my new book on the history of the monarchy. So I feel that I'm pretty well placed to answer this. So who are your finalists? Well, do you know what? I really hesitate to say this now, given what Tom's just said, but Henry V is up there. Oh, dear. We've got to revisit this.
这是一个非常切题的问题。这听起来像是在无耻地打广告，不是吗？但我刚刚完成了关于君主制历史的新书的最后润色。所以我感觉自己很有资格回答这个问题。那么你的决赛选手是谁？嗯，你知道吗？鉴于汤姆刚才说的话，我现在真的很犹豫要不要说，但亨利五世绝对在列。哦，天哪。我们得重新审视一下这个。
I was hoping for an Elizabeth Darby yeah maybe they'd both be there in the Elizabeth World Cup in the Elizabeth World Cup I also actually quite rate George V who kind of very big on stamps stamps
我本来期待的是伊丽莎白·达比，也许他们都会出现在伊丽莎白世界杯里。在伊丽莎白世界杯里，我其实还挺欣赏乔治五世的，他非常喜欢邮票，邮票。
and just yeah kind of no nonsense priestess trousers on the wrong side no i i'm sorry i'm sorry it's it's got to be it's got to be elizabeth the first and alfred the great oh okay alfred the great you're going back you think i mean you know they're both sorry my phone someone is hassling me on the phone i'm going to put that down um i think before we spiral off into a completely different podcast uh and i think i think tracy you must come back because i think this idea of rating monarchs is a great one and an enormous one and you can never talk about it enough oh um yeah i can't thank you i mean great
还有就是，那种务实……不，对不起，对不起，必须是伊丽莎白一世和阿尔弗雷德大帝。哦，好吧，阿尔弗雷德大帝，你回溯得够远的。我想……对不起，我的电话响了，有人在电话里骚扰我，我要把它挂掉。嗯，我想在我们陷入一个完全不同的播客之前，特蕾西，你一定要再来，因为我觉得这个评价君主的主意很棒，而且内容非常丰富，永远也聊不完。哦，嗯，是的，我不能……谢谢你，我的意思是，很高兴
to talk about elizabeth thanks so much for coming on it's been my pleasure thanks so much um dominic and i uh we'll be back next week and we are talking about history as entertainment, aren't we? So games. Board games, computer games. And games in history, so like war games and things. All that kind of war games, all that kind of stuff. And also we've got one on Persia and basically why everything comes from Persia with Ali Ansari. So I hope you'll enjoy that.
能聊伊丽莎白，非常感谢你来参加。这是我的荣幸。非常感谢，嗯，多米尼克和我，我们下周会回来，我们要谈论的是作为娱乐的历史，对吧？也就是游戏。棋盘游戏、电脑游戏。还有历史中的游戏，比如战争游戏之类的。所有那种战争游戏，所有那种东西。我们还有一期关于波斯的话题，基本上是关于为什么一切都源于波斯，嘉宾是阿里·安萨里。所以我希望你会喜欢那一期。
As ever, send your questions for both those topics on Twitter and an additional date for your diaries, April the 21st, the evening, it's a Wednesday. We will be doing the podcast live on the internet and the subject actually touching on something that we've been mentioning in today's podcast will be assassinations, assassinations over history from Caesar through to Kennedy. And we'll be sending out a link nearer the time everyone is welcome to tune in and watch us make fools of ourselves live but for now that's it thank you Tracey thank you to you for listening bye-bye it's been such a pleasure thank you thanks Tracey bye-bye Thanks for listening to The Rest is History.
一如既往，请在推特上发送你对这两个话题的问题。还有一个日期要记在日记里，4月21日，晚上，是个星期三。我们将在互联网上进行现场直播，主题实际上会触及我们在今天播客中提到的内容，那就是暗杀，历史上从凯撒到肯尼迪的暗杀事件。我们会在临近日期时发送链接，欢迎大家收看我们现场出丑。但现在就到这里，谢谢特蕾西，谢谢大家的收听，再见。这真是太愉快了，谢谢，谢谢特蕾西，再见。感谢收听《历史的余味》。
For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如需奖励剧集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在restishistorypod.com注册。网址是restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。